welcome back to another edition of The
Gadget Lab show I'm Michael colori and I
am over at the Baldwin and this week
we've got for you the fitbit zip mat
Honan review this on wired com but that
couldn't be here today to she's probably
out walking somewhere yeah right with
all this foot bit so Robbie and I are
going to tell you about it if you're
familiar with the old Fitbit you'll
notice this one looks a little bit
different you wear it you cook it's your
body you walk around it tracks your
movements or tracks here you know your
steps you take every day counts them for
you the number of calories you burn the
amount of distance that you've traveled
and if you're not that active if you sit
on your fat ass all day it starts to
frown aren't you Fitbit sad because
you're lazy but if you want to check up
on your stats you just tap the screen
tap the screen and you scroll through
them very nice little lifetime of a
future and it connects to your iPhone
yes but only your iPhone the Android app
is on its way and the Windows Phone app
is probably never coming although you
know it could be in the future just
don't count on Windows Phones coming
it's more than 12 people buying boom
then there will be a Fitbit app for it
it also you can connect it to your to
your desktop computer and when you sync
wirelessly by the way all the data comes
off the Fitbit goes on to your computer
and then you can look at all the charts
so you can see you know how you did
yesterday is compared to how you did
today you can earn badges so you can
imagine for things like 10,000 steps and
that's actually something else i should
mention is that with this you can if you
have a Fitbit you can also sense the
tracks calories burned you could enter
in the food that you eat but you can't
do that on this you have to do that on
the app so either on your phone or on
your desktop you got to go in after
every meal and tell what you ate and it
adds up all the calories and then
balances that with how many firm based
on how many steps you take
so if you're an overachiever person who
works out of time that's awesome yeah
but if you're someone who just like I
just need to start working out and then
you buy this guess what I don't think
you're going to like after about two
weeks you're going to be like I'm not
putting this stuff in anymore yeah it's
a bit of a drag to do that after every
single meal so if you're very dedicated
it's a good helping device but it's not
going to like actively make you work out
it won't turn you into Jack LaLanne no
so Robbie was thinking to be kind of
cool if you have one of these that
actually shocked you or had a loud it
made a loud noise because if it's shock
has to be on you but if you're not
if you're ignoring you have any other
room it makes this piercing noise like
when the night when the 9-volt battery
and your smoke detector is going bad so
you're like oh I gotta get that Fitbit I
got to do my 5,000 steps to do yes
because many where is always the best
kind of where it is it forces you into
doing something via irritation one other
thing we should mention is that there's
no there's no charging dock for this it
is a watch battery inside of it so it's
a little 3 volt battery you pop it out
you replace the battery and you're good
to go which is great except for the fact
that when the battery runs out it will
probably end up in the sock drawer with
that zune and all the crappy $30 watches
you bought over the years yeah and your
old iPhone yeah all that stuff so the
new Fitbit you can get it for around 60
or 70 bucks and it's available now it's
called zip the fitbit zip and you can
read mat Honan 'he's full review on wire
calm and let's bring on Alexandra
alexander's here hi and you have some
new details about the windows 8 roadmap
right so we got a bunch of new
invitations today one for windows 8 and
one for windows phone 8 so Microsoft
sent out a detailed invitation for its
windows 8 and surface launch and that's
happening in new york on october twenty
fifth and then maybe like half an hour
to an hour later it sent out another
invitation about Windows Phone 8 and
that's happening in San Francisco on
october 29th so almost back to back so
was that thursday thursday the 25th
monday the 29 so thursday we get to see
surface and the windows 8 operating
system right and then monday there's the
windows phone operating system why not
zoom all once honestly I don't know oh
yeah and why not do them completely
opposite side thank you from one another
three days apart you're there it's kind
of man yeah basically almost makes no
sense I think it's because they have
totally different product groups like
Windows 8 people they just do their own
thing over here then Windows Phone 8
people they do their own thing over here
and then they want their own separate
events they want stuff to be special but
then it's kind of a you know it's a
hassle for the tech press you know
windows 8 obviously it's going to be
showing up on desktops and laptops
forever right but surface is that the
big story that is the bones big story
now surface is gonna be the huge story
um basically microsoft hasn't given us
any time well maybe a couple minutes of
time of hands on but it's been really
light on the details in terms of pricing
especially that's a huge missing spec
and that is expected to be announced at
that event okay um what about what about
sales are they gonna put it on sale that
day they're going to put it on sale at
midnight following the event midnight of
the 26 which will then mean you can buy
it on stores in Microsoft stores and
pop-up stores and then online okay for
how much nobody knows yet
I guess we'll find out maybe that's the
Halloween present they're just gonna
like write a big check and dress up like
that yeah vulnerable services for
Halloween what do you think it's gonna
cost mmm my guess is around 5 99 600
bucks yes for the good wonder for the
rivet for the our teeth and not the the
lower tier one it'll be like an iPad
okay looking forward to it seriously
looking forward to it and it will have
news from the event yes Alexander will
be covering it and of course you'll have
all kinds of stories leading up to that
yeah which you can read on the gadget
lab we'll be back next week with more
products and maybe more details about
microsoft something announcements but
until then thanks for joining